[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
April 5th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
Americans who reached their limit with
long hours are experimenting with
working less a lot less wsj work and
life columnist Rachel feinzig joins us
with more hey Rachel thanks very much
for being with us thanks so much for
having me so Rachel we've heard from a
lot of people over the past several
years that the pandemic caused them to
reconsider their work commitments but
how much of a trend has this become I
think it's a real Trend there's data
showing that high earning men have
pulled back on their work hours we've
also seen the number of Americans
working part-time voluntarily so that's
for non-economic reasons rise over the
last year and then we've had this
experiment with a four day work week
which has really been taking place in
the UK but they've had a lot of success
over there and I think it's caused a lot
of companies and individuals here in the
U.S to think wow my life would be really
great if I had a three-day weekend every
week and so how are people who are
working less in the U.S filling out
their days I think some people are using
it as an opportunity to spend more time
with their kids sometimes that can
devolve into child care which I think a
lot of researchers say is is not exactly
what we want to see here like the idea
is that you're kind of spending less
time on work whether that's caregiving
responsibilities or actual paid labor
outside of the house so you want to be
spending time on things like Hobbies or
volunteer efforts there's also this idea
that you could maybe spend that time
doing errands all the logistical stuff
of being an adult you know that needs to
be done that we often spend our weekends
doing and that can free up more time on
weekends for us to just like be happy
and do things we actually enjoy you know
Rachel you mentioned the four day work
week experiment in the UK I got a lot of
publicity what are we hearing from
workers who participated in that a chunk
of them say that there is no amount of
money that would prompt them to go back
to five days a week overall people have
been happy and I think many people and
bosses feel like folks have been
productive I think some of the research
coming out of that show is that you know
these are people who hadn't really
thought about doing a 40 work week and
were really surprised to find how much
they liked it now some people will cut
back on their work hours but are they
really separated from work you know
given all the connected devices we have
yeah this is where this can totally go
wrong maybe you go down to part-time you
take a big cut to your pay and still
every Friday you're logging on because
you have demands from clients or
co-workers that you just feel pressured
to respond to there's also the sense I
think that you miss out on promotions
you miss out on key company decisions it
can be really hard to make this work and
with this story I really wanted to delve
into what this really felt like for
people and all the benefits but also all
the downsides that folks maybe don't
think about when they're just
fantasizing about how great their life
would be you know if they worked less
but to be sure not everyone has the
financial means to cut back on their
working hours to part-time right exactly
I mean a lot of people don't work in
jobs where you can do this where there
would be the opportunity to do this a
lot of people cannot make ends meet if
they're making less money Jr I have to
tell you a decent chunk of folks that I
talk to actually said they were making
the same amount of money especially if
they kind of went toward freelance and
contract work they were actually making
more per hour being on their own but
there's still a lot of risks and hidden
costs right like you know your health
insurance is no longer paid for and you
don't have paid time off and you're at
the whim of these companies and there's
a lot less stability so for sure there
are costs but again I was surprised to
hear that it's not always like a just a
totally slashing of your salary the
first year that you do this but is there
a learning curve to this you know
removing work from your schedule and not
feeling that you're slacking off yes I
heard about this from several
researchers who said that you know
especially if you start doing something
like the four day work week at First
there's kind of this period where people
are like what do I do just because you
have that time doesn't mean you're using
it well if you are just scrolling you're
not gonna feel great you really want to
be using that time for something that
still gives you purpose and makes you
feel productive I think that after a
while people get the hang of it and
realize like what a boon it is to their
lives but it can take a little while to
adjust
I mean Jr work serves a purpose in our
lives it gives us structure it gives us
purpose and self-esteem there was a
finding from a professor I talked to who
found that we don't need that much of it
to get that benefit but we do need that
and people who have too much time also
you know suffer from a lack of happiness
because we just feel adrift so it's all
about finding that balance of having
enough time and using it well all right
that's Wall Street Journal working life
columnist Rachel feinzig Rachel thanks
so much for being with us thank you for
having me and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]
thank you